[Music]
which one shall we name the dogs I think
he a he or she
oh yeah well she's shy ger and jane okay
what concept or music general would you
like to try in the future she is she
there never was a pudding tonguing it up
cuz they rock rock jazz no do you know
chip Baker yeah oh you want to pick it
more sexy Oh ta keo symmetric and I own
powerful powerful energetic good senior
a respectful senior sexy cool guys
handsome savage Jane picks one yeah oh
how do you feel you grow as an artist
between your first and second world wars
so particulate or the clothes I yeah I
just hope to get something about the
kitchen and I think over 60 and more
good English for small change a little
we mocked a little about his hometown
was well the people in drew he has a van
Gogh wreckage of
wasn't everyone and what's funny I want
all the flavor dogs he's not gonna know
if you could collaborate with any other
celebrity either solo or as a group who
would it be
Kluber so Kincaid or Sullivan you're
dating now these puppies if there's one
thing you could change from your past
what would you it'd be a generic 100 is
a rather positive abortion push with
each other yeah I know
present was from the past and the future
comes from the present so I like my
stuff right now
I agree you too yeah me too no tell them
to get a word for Joo Han and I am all
what are some of your favorite lyrics
that you've written Joshua I'm shaky
compassion for children cars on bottom a
student cousin and watching bio oh I
like my rat lyrics inside forever
because my lyrics are destroyer like
belief rap yeah I like it if you could
switch bodies with one member for a day
it be and why come on Paco cigar see
Daniel only been bother cause your cell
here's a good buddy thank you Hey focus
on me I'm sorry
concentrate I want wonho's body why the
car I want
hey focus on
I want apps you have no just water okay
do you have any tips on how to address
will like all of you what do you want
sex Susan do you what I'll just remember
Joe since the god don't you know Peppa
Pig our turn in people value is yes sir
follow me follow my outfit come on Tess
mix kitchen exquisite Harry Potter
Oh Harry Oh 100% Terry Puhl Twilight
vampire you cannot pick it up oh this
question it is first shuttle show you
just what do you like about being the
leader on Stan's
Musa's to do those items I had a twinge
of leaders I had a twinge um aha I think
I'm just leader
oh so energetic it's so cute
I want a tough v oh let's go home
together you can't adopt this cute
puppies I know what sure animal II
America stinking the changes face no no
no no no no no
[Music]